Now that we have created our ocean tool, let's take a look at creating our lake tool.
Now to add our lake, we do exactly what we did before.
We go up to our quickly add, we search for lake, and then we click and drag and drop it,
and we're going to get something that looks kind of like this.
Not exactly, but let's pop over to the editor and have a look now.
So again, quickly add, we're going to type in the word lake, and then we're going to
add our water body lake, and there we go.
We've got our water body lake added right to our particular map.
Now same with the ocean, we can click on the individual points here and adjust them.
We can also right click and add spline points.
If we come to our water body here and we go down to our curve settings here, we can adjust
the channel depth.
Remember this is going to act as the basically deepest point in our lake, and then we can
adjust the curve ramp width here.
This is going to affect the fall off.
And then underneath our water height map settings, we can do affect our fall off settings
here by affecting how the lake is going to go from the existing terrain down into the
lake itself.
We can also do all types of cool effects.
We can blur.
We can also add a little bit of curl noise.
Maybe one was a little bit too much, but we could do something like that.
There we go.
Point five gives us some kind of cool results.
So add just a little bit more in there.
We got some interesting looking lake going on right there.
But again, with the ocean and the lake tools, you're going to see that all of the settings
do virtually identical stuff.
So once we have kind of gone over the settings once, applying them and using different settings
is of trivial importance because once you've learned how they work once applying them to
other things is going to be very repetitive, but also super simple because you've done
this once already and you kind of know what each one has done.